[Musique]
il s'agit d'une urgence nationale
c'est une course de vitesse contre les
nazis
[Musique]
si les nazis ont
12 mois d'avance sur nous 18 et comment
vous pouvez savoir ça
il nous reste à espoir
en réunissant ici toute la puissance
industrielle et l'innovation
scientifique de l'Amérique dans un
laboratoire secret
personne n'en sortira avant que ce soit
fini
allons recruter des scientifiques
on construit une ville vite et on laisse
les chercheurs venir avec leurs familles
sinon on n'aura pas les meilleurs
quoi on irait s'installer dans un trou
perdu pendant je ne sais combien de
temps
pourquoi pourquoi
je vous dis que c'est l'événement le
plus important de l'histoire du monde
tu as un grand don d'improvisation mais
ça
ils peuvent sortir de ta tête
on estime qu'il y a un risque en
appuyant sur ce bouton
de détruire le monde le risque est
proche de zéro
le risque est proche de zéro qu'espérez
vous de la théorie brute le risque à
zéro ça ça me plairait
c'est une question de vie ou de mort
et je peux accomplir ce miracle
la Seconde Guerre mondiale serait finie
on ramènerait nos garçons au pays
le monde
n'oubliera pas cette date
le travail que nous faisons ici
garantira une paix que l'humanité n'a
jamais connu
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un crée une bombe
plus grosse
vous êtes l'homme qui leur a donné le
pouvoir d'autodestruction
or le monde n'est pas prêt
3 commande veut savoir ce qui se passe
ensuite